greetings planet Houston I am General
Zod and may I wish you all a merry
zodmas nothing says Christmas like
stuffing yourself like fat pigs
this is food well bad enough you have to
kill an innocent tree for your holiday
now you have to murder an innocent bird
and or swine our Krypton we eat recycle
clay mix with our disinfected feces this
can sustain us for many light years it
makes food fights troublesome I will
tell you our eggnog comes from but
coincidentally it is also frothy and
white I must admit for Cesar perpetual
love this alters in the center on the
murder of innocent plants and animals as
well as the murder of good taste have
you seen the inflatable Santa's this
year
speaking of lack of good taste fruitcake
it is neither fruit as far as I can tell
it's not really a cake but there are
nuts
this aggravates me why would you give
anything that already looks like it's
been thrown out and pressed into a brick
is this some form of cruel christmas
punishment if so I approve
lets us talk about candy canes this
Elise's truth in advertising it is candy
and they are cane shaped but I don't
like mint so it shall be purged from the
planet along with all memory of it let
us take a look at Christmas cookies
again why do you call them Christmas
cookies do they practice the religion in
the news our dunya Republic all cookies
will be atheist or at least agnostic and
they will all be Milano's because I like
the Mallos but not the mint kind don't
make me vaporize you raisins will also
be forbidden from all open cookies
because the wrinkly exteriors remind me
of the elders of Krypton who banished
media guilty it is you guilty reasons
cookies and what goes better with
cookies than the nutritious discharge of
cow breasts again you can stow unites
are all about peace and love this time
of year and you to enslave and animal
and play with these others for your own
amusement and even worse blinked at
amusement why don't you milk yourselves
on Krypton we milk ourselves all the
time our milk is a cobalt blue and it
sustains us we do not drink from our
Prairie animals we eat our disinfected
feces it's bitter crunchy taste makes us
power and just better than fruitcake the
similar texture final summer food does
not belong in the cydonia People's
Republic of Houston it is recycle
species for all with a side order of I
am General Zod and you will kneel before
me